your system has corruption so I guess
the bigger question is which system has
more corruption uh
the this this one with Central planning
and worker cooperatives versus uh
unfettered capitalism or any flavor of
capitalism I think any system has
potential for corruption I think it it
depends on like how good your civil
service is how how much oversight do you
have to resolve a problem once it arises
how does corruption happen in the social
system so you have to again I I
apologize but the large-scale examples
of it so we can we can look at Soviet
Union China and Sweden
uh fundamentally different nations and
histories and peoples and economic
systems and political systems but all
could be called in part socialists
and so what you know there there's a
ridiculous almost caricature of
corruption in the Soviet system the
gigantic bureaucracy that's built
um where somehow corruption seeps in
through kind of
dispersion of responsibility
that nobody's really responsible for the
corruption
I just had a conversation with Ed
Calderon who fought the the cartels in
Mexico and there's a huge amount of
corruption in Mexico but it's it's not
like even seen as corruption you're you
understand when the cop pulls you over
you give this much money and so on and
so that kind of seems to happen in
certain systems and it seems to have
happened in Social systems more than in
capital systems in the 20th century or
maybe I'm wrong on that no I mean I
think in a lot of countries it's seen as
the cost of doing business right now in
particular countries built on a system
of central planning or just State
allocation resources for the state both
producers and and allocates and things
run through bureaucracies
then I think you're you're much more apt
to have corruption than in a system with
just a smaller Sphere for the state so
for example if you're in a hypothetical
version of the U.S you might see a lot
more corruption like the post office but
you know you wouldn't have that
corruption in your workplace so you kind
of learned to go around that
um
for one thing even in state sectors you
can have and this often is the case in
Democratic countries you have
um a transparent Civil Service where
people who are corrupt are prosecuted by
judges where it's frowned upon and it
just over time it goes away so you go
from having political machines that were
tied to certain you know had friends and
certain police precincts and whatever
else in the U.S in the the 19th century
and early 20th century to now today that
would be a huge Scandal and unheard of
right so I think over time having a a
um
Independent Court System having a a
truly meritocratic civil service can be
implemented anywhere I think though in
the Soviet Union the extra
little bit that that happened was you
had a bureaucracy that just had so much
power because the bureaucracy was
producing and distributing everything
and everyone was relying on the
bureaucracy with jobs the way to social
advancement uh was through the
bureaucracies so you end up with people
like Khrushchev you know people going
from peasants to
um you know Supreme leaders of of
countries just through like getting
hooked up in the bureaucracy and
advancing within it um and you know not
all these were bad people yeah I don't
think Khrushchev was that bad of a
person or Gorbachev you know they they
but this is their mechanism to
advancement in systems like this in the
vision of democratic socialism that I
propose
the state doesn't have that overriding
power to begin with but I think in
either case you know corruption has
arose in many different systems and has
been successfully
um dealt with I think on the
developmental trajectory of even
countries today that we think of as
being very corrupt
um corruption will will
um you know fade away as well but you
definitely need a system in which
um individuals act
um individual are incentivized to act
rationally so if you're in a system in
which cops who are corrupt are
prosecuted and investigated and there's
internal controls a civilian Board
review and kind of an internal
investigators within police departments
or whatever else there will be less
corruption over time if people are
punished if you're in a system in which
if you're running a firm or you're the
manager of a firm and elected manager
and everyone at that firm is trying for
more efficiency and trying for more
excess profits or whatever else at the
end of the day you know dividends at the
end of the day then if you try to hire
your nephew and he's not good at your
job you're not going to win re-election
right so you you shouldn't
I think no system should rely on a
change in culture that come naturally or
some sort of individual altruism I think
the systems have to be constructed in
such a way that it's not rational to
behave poorly in sort of from a
theoretical perspective
either socialist or capitalist system
can have can have either culture
but it seems like if you prior to
prioritize meritocracy
if the people that are good whatever the
good means in terms of Integrity in
terms of performance in terms of
competence it's it seems like that leads
to a less corrupt system and it seems
like capitalism there's all kinds of
flavors of capitalism but capitalism
because it does prioritize meritocracy
more often leads to less corruption so
that's that's not a question of
political or economic systems the
question of what kind of stuff do you
talk about that leads to a culture of
less corruption
first of all I think it Theory maybe
capitalism words meritocracy
but I think in practice anyone watching
this or you and me would think of some
of the people we know that work the
hardest and they're often you know
Working Class People work in the food
service industry or whatever else right
um I I think we we don't have
um in practice I don't think we actually
live in a society that rewards people
for hard work I think we reward people
for a combination of accidents at Birth
plus hard work
let me push back because uh yes so I
agree with you but let me push back on
on a subtle point because I like to draw
a difference between hard work
and meritocracy because as a person who
worked really hard like I work crazy
hard but I've also worked with a lot of
people they're just much better than me
it's a hard work does not equal skill
good productive I just want to kind of
draw that distinction but I agree with
you
I don't think our society Rewards
uh directly hard work or even high skill
there's many examples that these people
can see that it does not do so so we
have an unequal distribution of talent
of course so if we lived in a society in
which there was some level of acceptable
inequality and it's a normative kind of
the question of how much we would say is
acceptable right
um and that inequality was based on this
unequal distribution of talent then I
think that would be fine with me right
that would actually be a meritocracy
what I see in the U.S is often
okay so if you are a upper middle class
or rich kid and you get a good education
you know K-12
um
out of those people there will be some
that work extra hard and go on to do
incredible things or very successful and
there'll be other people that
um do not right and and decide for
whatever reason or go down a different
path and you could say maybe among that
group of the alpha middle class you know
there is a meritocracy right
um but they're actually given those
opportunities to make their own
decisions and to to fail whereas many
many other people the vast majority of
American society I would say 60 plus
percent don't really get those
opportunities to make those choices to
to begin with and I would aspire to the
type of world at least as a as a first
step in which
um our only inequalities are based on
the our unequal um innate kind of
distributions of talent yeah I I guess a
lot of people worry that when you have a
a socialist in any degree Central
planning or perhaps a collective of
workers that it won't result in that
kind of meritocracy that you're talking
about but you're saying that no it's
possible to have that kind of
meritocracy think about it this way the
workers themselves are incentivized and
are shaped by market forces too right
they're trying to to respond to Consumer
needs and preferences they're trying to
expand market share they're trying to
make make money so it requires no kind
of leap into these people are going to
be more altruistic or whatever else even
on Purely Bourgeois terms the same way
you would maybe justify you know
competitive capitalist firms I think you
could justify this this system as long
as you think that that people elected
management can perform just as well I
think based on the experiences of
cooperatives we've seen that they they
can and then at the state level State
bureaucracies have their own sort of
sets of of of incentives but in most
systems that already have extensive
State bureaucracies of these people at
high levels are are appointed or
electeds they're held to certain
standards at the national level a
national government wants to maintain
you know the tax revenue that they need
to pay for school services so we already
I think have incentive structures that
you could say that some people might
just I think disagree with the normative
thing of like why would people have to
own their own means of production
control their workplaces or whatever
else uh why do we need this level of
equality
um can't we just get by with our
existing system but just like make
things a little bit easier for
capitalists to make money then everyone
will benefit whatever else I mean that's
a normative question and my vision of
socialism there'll be plenty of you know
multiple parties with different views
and perspectives trying to either push
us deeper into more radical forms of
Socialism or on the other hand to kind
of roll back to you know more capitalist
forms of of government so I think that
again you can't try to make up a perfect
system and try to implement it you have
to you know do it as a process
democratically and and so on so just
philosophically in your gut
you're more concerned about the innate
equal value of human beings versus the
efficiency of this wonderful mechanism
that we call human civilization are
producing cool stuff just like a gut if
we were sitting at a bar that's where
the gut feeling you come with of course
your mind is open but you you want to
protect the equal value of humans
so I don't want to fight the
hypothetical so I'll say equality I am
concerned with with equality but I don't
think the two are necessarily always in
tension
when you think about all the great
things that human beings have produced
often I think people today just look at
the end outcome like we go to the
pyramids and we'll Marvel at the
pyramids and and the human achievement
that it took to make it happen but we
won't
you know stop to think about all the
suffering that went into the making of
that thing so I think we kind of lean in
the opposite direction we'll remodel at
our achievements but we don't often
think about the suffering or
exploitation that went into certain
human achievements I would love a
society in which
we could Marvel at things and not have
to worry about the exportation that was
involved because there was no
exploitation or oppression involved
there was just human Ingenuity and
creativity and collaboration and to the
degree which you may disagree to the
degree there's a tension between the two
at least give equal way to the
consideration of the suffering
and don't just marvel at the beauty of
the Creations to the degree there is a
tension between them what what Stalin
did actually too it's not just capitals
but what Stalin did was he sacrificed
whole Generations because he thought
that he was building something for the
future for future Russians to to enjoy
and for future people of the world to to
enjoy and actually that analogy that I
just gave by the pyramids was
um was written by Carl kotsky the German
socialist anti-stalinist critic when he
was complaining about U.S journalists
and others going to Russia in the 1930s
and marveling at all the new Industries
you know are these people blind to the
suffering you know Behind these things
they're marveling about